shepard
may i speak with you
i was just thinking about you i have
been thinking about you too
and what we are about to face i do not
know what is going to happen on ilos
i hope we will stop sarin of course but
part of me fears we are already too late
there is something i must tell you in
case we fail
we're not going to fail i promise please
i am not looking for comfort saren might
already have the conduit
it is time to be completely honest with
each other these could be our last
moments together
our last chance to show each other how
we feel
i want this to be special we don't have
to do this
not unless you're sure i have never been
more sure of anything in my life
will you join with me shepard let our
bodies and minds unite
just tell me what to do
[Music]
[Music]
by the goddess that was incredible
shepard
you were incredible five minutes eta to
the mu relay
i had better go duty calls you would not
want to keep joker waiting
shepard whatever happens on ilos
i just wanted to say thank you
for everything
[Music]
[Music]
you